tenemos la desigualdad esta de aquí que
es dos tercios mayor que menos cuatro y
menos ocho con un tercio ahora lo
primero que quiero hacer aquí es
convertir este número mixto que
realmente molesto me incomoda muchísimo
de hecho es es difícil lidiar con el
matemáticamente así que vamos a
convertir esto aquí tenemos ocho un
tercio no es otra cosa más que algo que
va a llevar en el denominador un tres y
luego hacemos tres por 8 24 más 1 son 25
entonces podemos sustituir en esta en
esta desigualdad y tenemos dos tercios
es mayor que menos 4 y menos 25 tercios
muy bien y ahora lo que no me gusta
tampoco es tener fracciones en esta
desigualdad entonces lo que tengo que
hacer es multiplicar por algún número
que me quite todas las fracciones y el
primero que por ejemplo se me ocurre es
estrés entonces si yo si yo multiplico
en ambos lados por 3 por ejemplo puedo
ponerlo
de esta forma en realidad la desigualdad
no está cambiando verdad multiplicó por
lo mismo y además debo remarcar que
multiplicó por un número positivo si yo
multiplicará por algo negativo entonces
la desigualdad cambia se cambia de
sentido verdad sería un menor que es por
si multiplicó por cualquier número
negativo puede ser menos uno menos un
medio que se sale pero en este caso no
es así porque es positivo entonces esto
esto lo que me hace va a simplificar la
desigualdad y vamos a tener que 2 es
mayor que hice aquí distribuimos es
menos 12 y menos 25 verdad tres veces 25
tercios es menos 25 y ahora qué pasa si
yo sumo si yo sumo de ambos lados 25
para quitar este de aquí verdad sumo 25
de ambos lados sumo 25 y del lado
izquierdo que me queda lo que me queda
es 25 más 2 son 27 y esto debe ser mayor
que menos 12 y y éstos ya se cancelaron
verdad
entonces ahora sí tengo 27 mayor que
menos 12 y y para despejar la aie pues
tengo que dividir entre menos 12 verdad
entre menos 12 y el detalle es que estoy
dividiendo entre menos 12 o puedes verlo
como que estamos multiplicando por 1
entre menos 12 verdad menos un doceavo
entonces lo que vamos a tener es 27
sobre menos 12 y aquí incluso déjenme
ponerlo con otro color como
multiplicados por algo negativo o
dividimos por algo negativo el signo de
la desigualdad se voltea ok y acá me
queda menos 12 y sobre menos 12 ok y
esto bueno pues podemos simplificar lo
verdad en tanto el numerador como el
denominador tienen un tercio entonces
esto será menos si sacamos tercera parte
de esto es 9 sobre tercera parte de 12
es 4 que es menor que nuestra y ok
entonces aquí ya tenemos el resultado
digamos en realidad lo podemos poner de
la siguiente forma
y que ya es más grande que menos nueve
cuartos muy bien simplemente fue fue
cambiando los y si se te dificulta verlo
de esta forma puedes decir que ya es más
grande por ejemplo si lo pasamos a
fracción mixta verdad esto es menos
cuántos cuartos tenemos aquí pues
tenemos dos perdón cuántos enteros
tenemos dos enteros y un cuarto verdad 4
por 2 18 y 19 ahí está ahora qué pasaría
si yo quiero graficar lo pues pintemos
nuestra recta real por ejemplo puede ser
que aquí han del 0 a candle menos 1 el
menos dos aquí estará el menos 3 y así
en adelante verdad entonces hay que
ubicar el menos dos enteros un cuarto
con este color que se andará como por
aquí y hay que ponerlo con un circulito
vacío porque no lo estamos incluyendo no
estamos suponiendo que es también igual
entonces todo esto de aquí a la derecha
todos estos 10 tomamos tomamos todo lo
que sea más grande que este número que
es menos 2 un cuarto nos tomamos todo lo
que sea más grande y todas esas 10 son
válidas es el son son yes que van a
satisfacer la desigualdad